well guys I welcome to the World
Championship class here at the st. Louis
chess club today I'm going to be
covering a game of a player who's
playing in the candidates this year
still still competing at the highest
levels uh veselin topalov and he's not
doing so on the tournament so far but as
one of these been one of my favorite
players and I wanted to cover a game
from his greatest chess success that was
winning the feed a world championship
tournament in San Luis Argentina in 2005
I was right around when i first started
getting into chess so he was a player
who i got to see and look up to yeah
he's uh he's pretty well known for his
you know uncompromising style likes to
play our positions definitely one of the
best fighters in chat history yeah and
he's been world number one for you know
serious amount of time in the past so
there's been some you know other things
that he's known for you know some
certain matches he's had but nonetheless
he's given a lot to chess and I wanted
to cover a game so the game we're going
to look at today is Peter Leko against
veselin topalov Peter leg goes white toe
ball of his black and yeah for those who
don't know he won this tournament it was
eight players 14 rounds and the winner
became the world champion usually to
match format this was a tournament
format and he started off six and half
out of seven which is one of the best
starts in history maybe maybe the best
almost but one of the best starts and a
lot of that had to do with him playing
pretty sharp openings as black he's a
type of player who can win win win and
lose a lot because of his style and
repertory so this game
just playing black against Lego Lego
busy for c if c 5 you know he's
especially back then you played a lot
more Sicilians over berlin's let's say
Knight f3 d6 and they go into a night
off these are the main moves and just a
little bit about the opening white
decided play f3 here the main benefit of
three years you stop Knight g4
variations Bishop e3 really one of the
main most Nigerian opening the bishop
doesn't get to stay state safely on III
so f 3 and then Bishop e3 is that the
move water here top office e6 there
should be 3 p-5 and yeah this opening
White Queen side Castle castles black
usually King said castles is a very
sharp opening which happens when when
when the Kings decided to go on opposite
sides but in this game football's how to
play very risky variation which is not
me be fully correct but he enjoyed I
mean he plays lines that other people
aren't willing to play which is a lead
some more exciting game so Queen d2 is
what like why this is all mainline stuff
was black I mean why once the Queen's
that Gauss will play play play g4 and
put pressure on black before black is
developed if we see that white has spent
more time developing pieces black has
spent more time developing a pawn pawn
so you know that's why there's gonna be
some kind of some kind of play here some
some tactics because the position is
quite imbalanced already it plays be4
right off the bat a very aggressive move
kicking the night away the night goes to
a four in this case and I could go
somewhere else but a four is pretty safe
if in case white as to why can reinforce
the night with be three
but if you look at the night here in the
bishop here there is some potential on
some squares like this as long as that
night on d forward and move away then i
donate for is not stuck on on the rim
the rest of the game it has it has a bit
of a purpose but this is a prepared
variation i mean this is this was a
tournament so they're both pretty well
prepared here black plays Knight d7 for
those who don't know those opening well
the poem before is why can take the
bottom before that is not defending that
that is that is a feature in this
opening Queen takes before could have
been played but black has d5 and it's
really a you know d5 attacking the Queen
on before and hitting the pawn on e4 and
things get very very complicated but
black is recapturing the pawn on e4 next
move in regaining the material and
opening position up which is just people
who play this is black kind of you know
want that type of open open position
with a lot of counter play so why
doesn't take the pawn there instead
continues playing principal just
queenside castling I mean you can take
next movement and what not but you want
your you know get the rook into the game
so now now after Queen side castling the
ball plays d5 and you know for for newer
players this is this is some almost
unorthodox chess black is not developing
black is not castling and still playing
with the pawns almost entirely there's
only two pieces develop the night on d7
and I on f6 and yeah that's just you
know not what they teach you to do
develop your pieces get your king safe
and then do stuff like this so this is
very risky play even for even for a top
player who knows the structure this is
this is risky play that black is
undertaking here so after d5 why does
principle response just takes on d5
opening when you're ahead and
development you want to open up the
position so
takes on d5 otherwise otherwise the pawn
is being attacked though that is that is
something I mean it would be undesirable
to play Bishop d3 to defend this pawn on
e4 that was being attacked twice because
that Bishop also blocks the Queen on D 2
and the rook which had they had some
potential on the on the D file but now
they're blocked by the bishops oh so
white decides to take now you don't want
to have an isolated pawn or so black
dicks back with the night he takes d5
isolated ponds or not not what you want
and I takes d5 but the position really
hinges on tactics here black black is is
way behind the development but but still
still alive here Bishop c4 bringing the
last piece in and keeping the files open
you know now Rick 81 and yeah i mean
honestly to me the position looks quite
quite decent for white it's a sharp game
but why white white should be pretty
happy with how things are going so I
mean but this this was expected from
black playing this this variation he's a
playing with fire here so after Bishop
c4 knight Knight f6 otherwise if you
were to play like Bishop e7 and try to
Castle I mean knight c6 and black is
just getting killed how to show you from
the whites perspective this is like an
amazing amazing position just all the
pieces are developed everything is
everything is going badly for black here
the Queen asked to move the D file is
about to be taken so
black us to play very very precisely so
you plays Knight f6 and now it's a bit
different if 96 here the Queen will go
to c7 and it's not not game over yet I
mean the Sicilian is very much a tempo
opening and and here here still still no
clear way for white to break through
these nights are very very solid white
we need more more pieces into the attack
but yeah things can get really dangerous
quickly here to show us game they play
this opening a game that had happened
before this I think or around the same
time with was which kind of shows what
happens when black doesn't play this
properly I want to go into because it
doesn't go very long as black played
Bishop d7 the pala played a different
move the Bishop e7 looks very natural
developing and defending the night after
the natural moves work 81like played
Queen 85 here try to get the Queen away
from the dfl maybe queenside castle or
something and attack the night night
takes esox so this was a game and it was
a ended up being China's future number
one player when he was just a kid Wang
Hao who was now still one of the top
players in the world but he was a kid
here he was white and just 90 x 86
inches shows um i take c 6 giving up the
full piece fe 6 bishop d6 white just you
know through the kitchen sink at black
right right off the bat like this is
only 15 moves in i mean i'll show it
from White's point of view Queen a
five-night xe6 black text I mean has to
take that night it's
and Bishop e6 pretty a pretty a pretty
powerful powerful game from white that
that was one of the reasons why i mean
this this line doesn't have a very good
reputations black you'll never survive
until they get all the pieces out so the
word you use in chess usually four lines
like that is dubious like a dubious
variation so--but should be six you know
and this is just this is just terrible
moves like this there should be five
it's not not looking good I mean the way
the game went just to go go gooo Bishop
after Bishop b6 Queen a four-digit d5
Bishop e7 instead and now like why just
has so much compensation for the piece
the black can can can get the King safe
obviously black would be okay but that's
just it's too late now so the miniature
of this game finished very quickly
Bishop takes b7 night takes b6 rook
takes you six castles
rook takes seven so now white sub two
pawns instead of taking the rook on a
just took two three piece up two ponds
and after Queen takes a two queen d for
threatening checkmate and then Adam b6
Rock f6 was played Bishop takes eight
and the game was over so that was a nice
game that this line isn't played very
much but that shows that's kind of like
shows what happens happens often as
white gets all the pieces in right away
with the sacrifice sure but black is so
behind in development that sacrifices
are possible so this was this was like
just a slaughter that had happened in
the same variation so some similar
themes there but fortunately play Knight
f6 avoiding that because it does it look
like it didn't look like almost anything
was missed in that game that was pretty
convincing so after Knight knight Knight
f6 black played white play Bishop g5
that's nice I mean wants to open up the
file for the rook and you know that
Bishop doesn't necessarily want to give
up that Bishop anyway so you know just
just improving where the bishop is and
freeing up the e-file for the rook now
there is also a strategical threat
like Bishop e7 well just like okay 96 is
annoying but yab white is also
threatening to just take theirs this is
a pretty annoying pin ideally of those
nights would like to take back so a
bishop takes f6 ideally block would want
to take back with a night that doesn't
want to isolate the pawns and same here
so that's why black between c7 if the
bishop takes d5 now that night can take
back because the queen is no longer
pinned so it's just moving the Queen out
of the way but like still still the
development isn't really being fixed her
yeah and the top off had played some
other move almost any other move you
might already be lost although in the
game still found themselves in some
trouble but yeah I move like Bishop e7
which I keep seeing Rick 81 so natural
there should be seven you have to deal
with moves like night f5 pretty thematic
pretty thematic move dangerous ideas
here so flip through them a little bit
Queen c7 and now Bishop takes d5 was
played
I mean the Queen was attacking the
bishop and if any material should be
three
maybe something like age six you know
there are some there's a chance that
black might get to escape the bishop age
for Bishop d6 with the idea of
developing the bishop and trying to
castle and they also threatened Bishop
f4 black black black is probably getting
away it's a really really tactical game
so you know blacks mean counter players
is going to be with like like that
dynamic just making threats knocking
he's not going to be able to really
develop in a safe way but moves like
this like Bishop d6 that develop and
also have a threat that's that's how
blocks trying to hold the balance so why
didn't really want to give that time so
after Bishop this [ __ ] takes d5 Knight
takes d5 here again like taking what the
pawn it's just really bad we're catching
one check God you know play Bishop e7
and you sound something like this is
already just losing losing just black is
totally busted Queen takes f6 I don't
know all the moves are very bad so I
mean these are all for smooth Knight
takes d5 next move for white pretty
self-explanatory Rock 81 I'm not sure I
would have given up the bishop on d5 but
white the black still isn't out of the
woods yet
so after work 81 there's still still
some ideas on the on the east I mean you
know if it should be seven I'm not even
entirely sure but it moves like night at
five look look pretty pretty scary an
example he takes out five and queen
takes d5 hitting the rook on a eight and
threatening rook takes you seven so I
mean I it's these are positions i don't
play myself it's just it's very you have
to be you have to be really informed and
making sure you're seeing all the
tactics because if you slip up any any
single move it's just losing four for
black so we should be 5 95 per kg 11 and
now Bishop d7 so night take c 6 here for
those one I mean you know it's not it's
not quite enough probably with a night
not you know the night the king the King
seems to escape he might be able to like
even high to g8 i'm not sure but it's
not super clear but it's not convincing
for white for sure there are no more
checks and or clear forcing moves they
should be seven
lako found a pretty good move quinta de
to also have to say at this moment Peter
Leko was around the peak of his career
he had just tied a match against
Vladimir Kramnik where he almost you
know won the match he lost the final
game and you know he was he was ranked
top five in the world at this moment so
these were this was you was a very very
strong player with white and he has a
pretty serious advantage in this
position very well prepared and not
really making any inaccuracies so far so
cool okay um quit yeah so Queenie to its
threatening Knight takes c6 now though
the Queen takes on your six that's a
whole different story all right so like
Bishop is 796 it's a very obvious you
know and Queen takes and this is just
you know lost once again black is losing
because even though White's down
material in the attack weight is out
material the rock on hate it works on 88
and 88 or not in the game so these
positions just fall apart
so after Queenie to I mean black black
chasm has some really really serious
issues anyways because black ended up
playing Queen d6 there aren't too many
unfortunately there are not not so many
moves to play here 96 is happening Queen
d6 so pretty you don't want to move your
queen too much in the opening but in
this case there's no other way to stop
night tix i take c 6 there's no even
like in between those or counter play
yeah so native for that of so neta for
I'm thinking potentially taking taking
and King be one
a queen d 6
a pretty artificial moon but necessary
and our King be one was played and
that's so so so typical like Oh solid
it's a prophylactic move black still has
some issues to solve but it was what one
moment in the game there was others as
well why could have used that time this
move to really put pressure on black and
you won't have some ideas for for white
dude instead of King be one white had f4
f4 is very annoying because like Bishop
e7 yes you know Nate f5 now potentially
good for good for white but the real is
after F for that night night night of
four you know same thing take on f4 play
King b1 and sacrifice on g6 each six is
a move that can look a bit annoying
because bishop age for Queen takes up
for but I think here you didn't look any
further because you know move like yeah
there's there aren't too many moves for
white here the dr. Bishop is super
important if it goes away then black is
safe to play Bishop e7 or something but
there was like night takes you six same
idea but now Queen h5 check and then
Queen to to f7
a sample line would be something like
Bishop e7 and rook takes you six
with 95 tons of pins all over the place
yeah well we'll see you but you know you
did miss some chances so far f4 is maybe
the first the first stat is you know not
not the hardest to see even so Queen d6
King be one now each six was played so I
mean white was right to anticipate age
six but what we're tactics to stop it
and and once again after here I mean f5
is also a pretty strong threat next move
just playing at five as well so it's
pretty forcing for black in terms of
white black can try so after each King
v1
age 6 this ship age four
well now the bishop is it can be blocked
at some point with g5 the first night f4
now I mean now black can breathe bit you
know some some relief here like it's not
there's no longer have for coming in but
you still can't play Bishop e7 it was
night f4 Queen f2 and Queen c7 so this
sequence night up for trying to get the
king queen off of the e-file you can't
play 23 company for you my 25 which will
just lose to tonight g6 some tactics I
mean at this I'm sure white play the
next move very quickly because just set
of principles like principal sponsors
you don't want to trade queens your head
and development is white you want to
attack you want to keep pieces on the
board so there are very few moves that
would like work for that Queen d2 and
Queen f2 so why it's definitely trying
to to get black before black and
consolidate and castle so after Queen f2
Queen c7 let go finally now he's played
it you know this that makes a more
committing move Knight f5 the truth is I
mean this position looks really really
risky to me for black it still looks
very good for a white and not many
people would play this type of position
or go into these positions and and have
some sort of confidence but the ball to
evolve is a player like that night so I
mean here you can't play Bishop e7 I've
almost no mousses white as black
but night f5 gave the ball of some some
fresh air that wasn't necessary he took
the chance here and got some of his
pieces of what what what truly do is
back here there aren't actually almost
any move so if you find any reasonable
move it might already be correct any
Sicilian players here what you do is
black and you can make some weaknesses
blacks already made a lot of weaknesses
just keep keep keep the position alive
there you go g5g five but you know that
Bishop was way too strong on on h4 g5
Bishop g3 and now rook c8 instead
instead of night f5 actually white had
another interesting move that had to do
with this night on 84 Knight b6 trying
to get the night into a game that's
important thing as you can do Queen
takes b6 Knight takes six and you know
double check mate you know or 97 and in
the issue with these positions is
material doesn't matter that much in the
sense that lets say Queen takes c6 rook
takes c6 9066 black has two pieces in a
rock for Queen that's often that's
normally supposed to be more than Queen
11 points 29 but because of the position
and development blocks never going to
you know see that see that see those
that rook or anything just something
like Queen B 6 here and yeah development
is going to lose the material but before
you never try to consolidate
so material a material doesn't doesn't
matter too much night Knight b6 would
have been a very very strong move Ripley
89 f 5 now
but anyways neither five still doesn't
lose the advantage black can't be you
know that comfortable even here after 68
but probably pretty happy that some some
lines were missed so after rook c8 now
ok c 2 is being it rook c8 is almost
always where the rook goes in Sicilian
that is where there's a/c file for black
a free file like that's that's that's
usually the open file for black so and
besides there's no way for black to
Castle so he's trying to make as many
useful moves in this position as
possible pretty much every single
positions like black is making a move to
extend his position give himself one
more move there's always only one or two
moves in each and every position but
long is still still breathing then he's
he's happy so after rook c8 here what's
a pretty natural move for white I guess
it's not that natural in some ways but
pretty pretty strong what lay coded here
is quindi for so c2 is hanging the rock
on h8 is hanging and I think also you
just I think whites confident that in
case there's a big tire tactical
sequence why will you know and end up
ahead usually the side with the better
developed pieces you know is going to
win these trades like a Queen takes
Queen take C to check where to happen
you know just King a 1 and h 8 is
hanging and black doesn't have any time
to win any material Queen d7 is Jack me
so it doesn't black can't really go go
for that pond so it's a pretty immediate
response by the balls by brooke g work
g8
so now I mean white has been playing a
bit more aggressively and I mean can you
improve the position almost any more for
white I mean the only other thing is to
get that net on night from a foreign to
the game so Knight b6 yeah feel free to
ask any suggestions because there are a
lot of options it's very sharp position
so what happened in the game more things
could like a game is only glimpse into
what could have happened in the position
both especially why it had lots of
options here 9 p-6 maybeee rook rook da
here you're saying a Bishop c5 Queen d7
right Queen text e7 night tix here and
Knight f6 check is coming yeah that
looks pretty good after Knight b6 I'm
guessing work th couldn't be the move
although you know even then it's a quick
trade everything off hmm still doesn't
look I guess I guess it's okay I guess
black might be escaping yeah those two
nights hanging here so nay p6 rook t8
which is similar to what happened in the
game I think you're a white white got
very frustrated the thing is so the time
situation this game is interesting on
white had spent a lot of time looking
for clear wins and was all getting at
the time trouble probably part of its a
bit of frustration that nothing has been
found yet I mean the position could
hardly like it's why it's done almost
everything nights on at five then I
don't have five is only very like this
is really strong Bishop on g3 spinning a
night got the open D file night on a
four is is good and bad there was a
chance earlier to activate it but you
just think when your opponent's king is
in the center of that you could do a bit
better and after all all this white made
a very like big big mistake in this
position rook g8 you know that's a
natural and now a big mistake from white
white played c3 trying to get the night
into the game no politics III night
takes you three probably
because with a real kanji why it's not
even worried about black developing
because the king is never catch them so
like Bishop c5 here okay you could play
96 anyways we're probably something like
Queen f6 like there's just the king is
permanently stuck there was no more
castling anymore nothing so why was
banking on on just getting that night
back into the game like that or if not
you know if something like a five maybe
you know take you know playing playing
like rook c1 or taking here and opening
it up but c3 was a big-time trouble
mistake so yeah brooke t it was played
and unfortunately why it has to trade on
d 8 because if you move the Queen away
anywhere blacks next moves going to be
Rick d8 takes d1 and that'll deflect the
rook from the e-file which means the
night on f5 will be free to take so the
Queen has to take on da there's no like
good square on another file Queen Queen
III I think what happens is going
through I remember 23 might be a move I
think Lego was probably worried about
you know moves like rook takes rook
takes maybe like Queen c6
I don't know Knight takes
the move here actually the bishop c6 I
think Bishop c6 was the move I think the
idea there is like if you play Knight b6
to play Bishop c5 like every single move
like you know these games take a lot of
energy for the players so so why really
was finally made a mistake after getting
time to a little bit yeah maybe maybe
Bishop c6 and there's no good way to
move the night you can't put it on c5
and otherwise yet you have to end up
trading Queens or the piece anyways
Bishop c5 the tactics are starting to
work for black so white I mean
fortunately has to trade everything off
93 but now I mean this end game this is
where black black black has a chance
Bishop c6 first precise you don't want
to take on c3 one play Bishop c6 so that
you can [ __ ] White's pawn structure
next move so Knight b6 pawn takes c3 on
Dixie street and Bishop g7 what happened
in the middle game was kind of
reminiscent to a few games that top all
have had in this tournament there's you
know a few sharp games but he emerged
ahead in all of them like risky
positions whatnot but but in this
tournament he was coming out of the
middle games as the one ahead and and
when that happens and it's all about
converting and this is this is a now
it's now it's just the conversion part
black is better because of the two
bishops that's that's simple as that
better pawn structure with two bishops
and whites nights are pretty pretty bad
here they don't have exalted squares no
no good outpost so after taking on c3
Bishop g7 this [ __ ] takes f4 otherwise
the night a sustained a 3g two is always
hanging there's a Bishop f4 you don't
really have too many other moves King
has to go to see two otherwise the
defense III at some point the [ __ ] yeah
that the night doesn't wanna be tied
down to g2 so Bishop takes up for he
takes up for I mean psychologically it's
hard to play this is white your head in
the game took too much time couldn't
find a winning attack probably got
obsessed with one or two moves that
didn't end up working and now you have
to suffer a very unpleasant in game so
so white yeah this is this this part of
the game was pretty pretty difficult for
white to old 91 this should be five
trying to play King c7 next move and
drop the night
with a four was played the idea is if
that a move like cc4 is played Black is
just happy to have that diagonal open
and they're just going to move you know
the bishop back and play a king c7
Bishop g4 or even Bishop b4 right now
that this would be for right now is
probably the straightforward reply no
matter what white does bishop d4 or King
c7 so provoking you know holes those
bishops we should operate well with with
weaknesses and with the pawns further
advanced and weaker the bishops through
also now just the two bishop things two
nights a4 is played Bishop d3 check King
see one now King c 7 a-5
cute little move here bishop okay
opening up the G file which not only
works to hit the pot on g2 but you might
want to just swing your book along the
fifth first this should be five and now
why wasn't I'm trouble that's it for the
rest of the game and there's not really
a good way to defend you too which is
very annoying you try to yeah you don't
really have a good way of defending g2
you move the night is bit about five and
you're hitting see three ng to anyways
so so King due to a bit should be five
rook g1 now Bishop c6 so Bishop takes f3
is coming King you two defending that
Bishop b5
so if move like 94 Bishop b5 so i can
even you can't move that night away and
Bishop b5 one of the ideas is maybe to
just play calm visual d6 Bishop c5
that's why ya in the Sicilian the two
bishops is very important usually
because it's really really open so c4
bit should be for net f2
next move for black here Black Sea
making weaknesses for last time moves
exactly bishops III bishops III not even
like you know why give up the bishop
pair to win upon when you can just win
upon cleanly so bishops III the the
collapse in position is pretty fast you
guys I've noticed like what add all the
pieces around the King and now almost
nothing no counterplay 94 Bishop takes a
5c 5 and the Knights trapped of five and
white resigned not really any good moves
here you'd have to move your night back
you can't really go forward 96 is
impossible Knight f6 gets kicked out
right away and then you'll lose the
second pawn on I mean yeah you're going
to lose the second part on c5
but this game is very typical of the
ball he's really a fighter at the board
and you know not always the best
prepared although he's well prepared but
relies a lot on his energy during the
game and and surviving the tactics but
this was this was one of this was one of
the most important games that he won to
get the world championship because in
this in this in this game he was he was
objectively lost actually for example in
that night p6 variation the
complications don't turn out well
there's quite a few quite a few very
very difficult variations here but just
one slip-up really one slip-up already
and he played everything else very
precisely so it's I enjoy studying his
games because you know whether he's on
the good side of the bat set there's
tons of tactics and you know themes
going on that are pretty pretty good for
anyone wanting to study you know open
positions or calculation any anything
sharp so at that's that's a it's a game
Lego top all of San Luis 2005 that we
survived